[Music]
with amtrak's lower fares you can travel
across the country and back for just 275
or less or turn a one-way ticket worth
over fifty dollars into a round-trip
ticket for just seven dollars more
that was the commercial for amtrak from
1985.
this morning amtrak and other train
services are back on track at the
busiest station in the country the
company spent almost two months
repairing tracks at new york's penn
station more than 650 000 people and
more than 1300 trains pass through penn
station every day the massive summer
project at the bustling hub involved 360
workers installing 897 track ties and
this is just the beginning of upgrades
needed for the sprawling amtrak system
nationwide amtrak's new president and
ceo richard anderson joins us once again
at the table good morning to you mr
anderson last time you were here as
president of delta now they brought you
out of retirement for the trains yeah
i'm very fortunate what you didn't have
and you're not getting paid you're not
getting paid to do this you came out why
uh to serve
because amtrak is an iconic brand in
america and it provides an essential
service to many communities and of
course in the northeast corridor it's
critical to people getting to work every
day it's not about controversy go ahead
will we ever have the quality of trains
that they have in japan and in other
places in the world like parts of europe
well we're challenged in that regard
because by and large our passenger
trains run on the freight rail networks
and in countries like japan and france
they have dedicated
high-speed
much straighter tracks that are built
for
a very different passenger experience
and we haven't allocated or made the
public policy decision in our country
except for the isella in the northeast
quarter
to make those sorts of investments yeah
in japan they go 200 miles an hour here
they go 150 miles an hour do you see
that changing
um not in the near term not unless we
make the infrastructure investments
to support high-speed rail and and as
you think about how the demographic of
our country is changing from what it was
a hundred years ago to people moving to
urban areas and very concentrated urban
corridors number one and number two the
growth of ride sharing where people
don't own cars and they use ride sharing
more and more
mass transit and commuter trains should
play a more important role in how we
live in urban areas so what do you
consider your imperative first
imperative is to get the infrastructure
fixed
and the work we did at penn station
shows amtrak can do a great job doing
this and we have a lot of investment to
make in the northeast corridor second
we've got to clean up our trains run our
trains on time
fix the interiors of our trains
and grow our services in the regions
that provide the highest levels of
service to the communities around the
country what kind of window are you
looking at i mean how monumental is that
you took delta from a small southern
carrier to what many feel is the is the
best u.s airline the biggest u.s airline
amtrak's in uh
a lot of trouble uh penn station's been
in a lot of trouble how how long does
that take if you think you can turn it
around how long does it take to do that
well it's a multi-year effort and part
of the planning process
with our board is to lay out what those
plans are a long-term fleet plan a
long-term engineering plan and of course
the gateway project here in new york 10
years 20 years
well it took 10 years at delta so it'll
it'll be a multi-year project let me put
it that way and making the switch from
planes to trains was it a learning curve
for you did you look in the you had no
real experience did you look in the
mirror and say i can do this or were you
a little concerned well you're always
concerned when you don't know the
subject matter so it's exactly it's a
lot of homework idea how do you move
people in one place to another yeah it's
capital intensive it's a network
business safety is really important
customer service is important very
similar on the other hand it's very
different technology but i'm fortunate
i have a co-ceo
who also came out of retirement on a
volunteer basis wick mormon how'd they
convince you guys to do it
huh
well i i wanted to serve in some
capacity okay
so tell me about this the terms of the
future is there technology happening uh
that might be uh dramatically changed
the way transportation works in
america well if you think about the
technology
well i mean the the thing we could do is
if we could just get our train speeds up
and operate more non-stop service in
very
densely populated urban corridors it
would be a great service to to the
traveling public in america think about
what asella has done
and we're on the verge of putting a
newest newest seller system in place
that what is the new seller well we're
right now we're under construction on on
replacing the current asella fleet with
uh 28 new acela train sets that are
going to increase the capacity about 40
percent
and allow us to do um half hourly
service from uh washington dc to new
york and new york to boston on the hour
there was also talk that they're going
to make the the space between the seats
shorter could you please make sure they
don't do that well we're not going to
make the space between the seats shorter
that was
an idea you heard that rumor well we
talked about doing it because one of the
questions we've had is making it more
affordable i mean remember the thing
about
much of what we do at amtrak our average
fare is about eighty dollars
and on the commuter rails it's even less
than ten dollars on average
but the bottom line is we want to make
it affordable and usable for people and
one of our great advantages is there's
no middle seats there's tons of leg room
our coach on amtrak
is much much better than first class on
an airline so you're not going to change
the seat spacing no okay should you
privatize it
well the question is i mean you can't
really privatize it because
there are pieces of it that have to be
subsidized i mean you could privatize if
you wanted the pieces that are
profitable but that wouldn't make a lot
of sense i mean look this is basic
infrastructure
we subsidized
[Music]
i think the subsidy last year for
highways was about 45 billion the
subsidy for aviation was about 16
billion and when you think about what we
do and what's sort of fundamental to
public policy it's to fund
infrastructure all right richard
anderson so far so good the summer of
hell did not happen here in new york we
actually did we did a great job and
thanks to our partners at long island
railroad and new jersey transit thank
you sir